in our series the road to 2020 we are
talking to current and prospective
presidential candidates about issues
affecting the country Democratic senator
Amy Klobuchar of Minnesota announced her
candidacy in February as you can see in
a lot of snow and now she serves on the
Senate Judiciary Committee and took part
in the questioning of Attorney General
bar earlier this week senator Klobuchar
joins us first on CBS this morning to
share her new plan for addiction
prevention and treatment we're gonna get
to that in just a minute because I know
it's a cause that effects has affected
you personally but first you just heard
the Speaker of the House accused the
Attorney General of a crime what's the
remedy well first of all the minimum
what the Attorney General did before
Congress was misleading at the maximum
he wasn't telling the truth he basically
was asked well what do you think about
the what Muller thinks about your report
and what you did and he just said I
don't know and it turned out there was a
letter there was a conversation so the
to get to the real nub of the facts
we've got to get Bob Muller in to
testify there's absolutely no way we're
gonna be able to figure out what
happened here especially when it comes
to Russia if we don't have Muller come
before Congress so once you get those
facts you can figure out what happened
of course the Republicans who control
the Senate has not said that they will
bring Robert Muller to testify but you
have a specific question for him about
the president's taxes what's at issue
there well when during the hearing I
just kind of on the spur of the moment
asked the Attorney General well the
president has said that he assumes that
Muller looked at his taxes looked at the
financials on his organization and then
suddenly I asked him and the Attorney
General the United States said well I
don't know if we looked at it and I said
you don't know he said no I don't know
you'll have to ask Bob Muller so I said
okay and now if they don't call him Bob
Muller I wrote a letter yesterday and
said I guess they're not going to call
you in or you must come in but please
get me these taxes is there anything the
Senate Democrats can do to get Muller in
well Lindsey Graham as the chairman of
the committee could demand that he come
in yes and so we will continue to push
our Chairman to get Bob Muller in
because when you really stand away from
all of this what really matters to the
American people
no matter if you're a Democrat or
Republican you do not want your election
invaded by a foreign country they didn't
do it with missiles they didn't do it
with a tank but they did it and the FBI
director has been very clear the head of
intelligence has been clear this
happened and they're getting bolder so
that's why we need to protect our
elections with things like my secure
Elections Act bipartisan backup paper
ballots make sure there's audits and
repeatedly the White House has stopped
us in our tracks from passing a bill
that would actually greatly help our
security in addition to your work on the
Senate Judiciary Committee and Congress
you're also now campaigning for
president how many people are in the
race now on the Democratic there are a
number of people in the race I'm not
counting focus on my own campaign going
to Michigan today and then to Iowa and
people out there while they are asking
here and there about Muller report and
things like that I can tell you they're
overriding concern Nora is making sure
that they don't get kicked off their
health care something this week the
Trump administration filed a brief to do
in the Fifth Circuit and so their
concerns are bread-and-butter concerns
about how can I get my kid to college
how can I Drive down a road without
being into traffic I mean I don't have
to tell you this but I think a lot of
Americans believe what's happening in
Washington is not addressing the
concerns and problems that they have at
home at the top of that list to
addiction prevention opioid abuse it's
rampant it is the most surprising
question I get everywhere and part of it
may been because of my own experience
during the Cavanaugh hearing I had the
opportunity we'll call it to talk about
my dad and how he literally as a
newspaperman and a columnist and
Mountaineer climbed to the highest
mountains but then sunk to the lowest
valleys because of his problems with
alcoholism how did that shape your
approach to policy well he had three
DWIs and what I saw was on the third one
that made him go to treatment that was
it because he was facing jail time and
when he went to treatment in his words
he was pursued by grace and so that has
pushed me as well as my work as a
prosecutor to say you know we want to
give people a chance and whether they're
addicted to opioids or meth or crack
cocaine which by the way those drugs are
acting people of color more than opioids
or alcohol we've got to give them a
chance people in America are saying how
can I get help and that's why we need
more beds for both mental health and for
addiction so that people have a place to
go so they can get that help we need to
focus on suicide prevention 30% increase
that times how do you pay for this I
have it all set out you pay for it first
of all with the two cents per milligram
fee on those opioids on those
manufacturers that have been making so
much money the drug companies the pharma
companies on opioid addiction they made
the money they should pay for this
treatment do you think there is
possibility of bipartisanship here and
big chance
there already is bipartisanship and
that's why I think I have tried to
approach this campaign by coming up with
ideas one people are actually talking
about because we can protect the law and
do policy at the same time and to that a
reality can get done and this is
something so many Americans are crying
out for so let's get this done senator
Klobuchar thanks for joining us here
thank you it's great to be on thanks